flippity is this is a real person still
very much alive and healthy what was his
reaction to the film because this is
such an intimate portrayal of this great
event in his life what did he think
about it well he he actually invested a
lot into this movie you know he in fact
he insisted that he be the one to teach
me to walk on the wire yeah and not to
dodge your question he ended up really
loving the movie but yeah but I spent
like eight days straight with this guy
and you know not everyone who's good at
doing something is also good at teaching
that thing so I wasn't sure how it was
gonna go but it turns out he's a
fantastic fantastic teacher I don't even
understand how someone can be teach you
it's one of those things where I think
you either know how to do it or you
don't because standing on a little tiny
wire like that and being able to walk I
don't know how you would do it the first
time yeah I wouldn't last one second on
a wire so actually on the second day we
did a thing that's called the baptism of
the wire which is kind of an old ritual
in wire walking right where the wire
Walker takes someone out of the audience
who doesn't know how to do it and puts
them up on the wire and and the person
who doesn't know how to do it leans on
the shoulders and walks behind the wire
Walker and unless there are total spaz
they can do it because the wire Walker
is so good at keeping their balance so I
wanted to do this with me put me up on a
high wire not as high as 1300 feet in
the air like the World Trade Center but
it was you know it was six feet off the
ground which was high enough right um
you can go get seriously hurt
if you fall six feet yes and in fact
that's why I had a safety harness time
because of insurance reasons you know
doing a movie like this what we did the
first crossing but after we did that
first crossing he started telling me oh
this is sort of emblematic of how
Philippe is he's like so um so it's very
curious now how they how they have
different technologies with the safety
harnesses you know for example you're
wearing an old-fashioned safety harness
but I have a new one here and it goes
like this it says look at this safety
harness it's almost invisible they make
this new kind of safety harness
technology in Russia of course there's
nothing there at all he's right right
right he's like so I I'm I would ask you
if we do another crossing would you like
to wear this safety honest
would you like to wear this one and I'm
like oh I'll wear the the invisible one
sure that would not be my aunt yeah but
he kind of quartered me right sorry he
takes off my safety harness and then he
goes about actually like doing a bit
where he mimes this fake safety harness
and like pretends to put it on me right
he's like okay now let's do another
crossing right okay so then we did
another crossing where I really didn't
have the safety harness on and this is
this is the kind of teacher he is he
wanted me to really feel at least a hint
of the fear of what it's like to be up
there without any safety measures right
and it sounds like he's the guy who also
infected emissions test for Volkswagen a
thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy japanese pornography